all right we're back in atlanta georgia
and i got my man d
shawn watson
is so freaking awesome it's good to have
you man that's great we're over here at
quarterback corner you like that song
that's what i made up for you
you do i'm sticking with it so you
better keep playing all right
really important deep dive question for
you here
super bowl snacks we'd like you to rank
these what are you going to be doing if
you see this on your table sunday where
are you going first
he's going wings one
piece of two pizza two
nachos three nachos three
slider i'm gonna probably go chilly
and then the sliders all right he went
wings one guys back to you mike we're
coming over all right wings i i agree
with you deshawn wings number one pizza
number two and i don't need the others
you give me the wings and the pizza and
i'm good to go
all right well desean's going to be with
us over here at the desk chris sims
coming over as well we got a full hour
of pft live still to come peter king
here as well what happened to beer for a
super bowl that's not a snack that's not
a snack that's just presumed you're
going to have beer peter we know that
with you there's always going to be beer
it's just what kind and how much of it i
like beer what's your favorite beer
right now my favorite beer right now is
probably sweet water blue it's an
atlanta beer a slight tinge of blueberry
in it it's delicious delicious mike
deshaun do you have what's your favorite
beer
i don't drink beer
i'm with you i'm not a beer drinker
either no it's not my thing yeah i mean
i am for one and then that's it i got to
go sit down and just enjoy the football
game it's great to have desean watson
here with us we got plenty of questions
for you sean and we were we were proud
to see you come back from that knee
injury that you suffered back in 2017
and have a spectacular season underrated
i think a lot of people need to
appreciate what you're doing in houston
it's really special and we think you
guys are heading in the right direction
as 2019 approaches the direction we're
hiding in is we're heading in is one
full hour of pro football talk live here
on nbcsn it all gets started live from
atlanta right here and right now
[Music]
working out of the gun watson fake the
handoff
fake the end around watson swings it
downfield wide open down the right
sideline catches made deandre hopkins
gallops into the end zone touchdown
houston
watson to hopkins it's lethal
it is it's pro football talk live from
atlanta and look who we have
sean watson the star quarterback of the
houston texans joining peter king chris
sims and i'm mike florio it's our
nobody wants to smell you all right
we've been smelling some of what deshawn
watson's been cooking on the field you
like what i did there some of his top
plays from 2018. chris you've put them
together deshawn you'll see them in the
monitor chris take us through them all
right deshaun we're going to go through
a few things here uh i mean first of all
awesome year but this is of course one
of the best right here the deep cross
bomb thursday night football de'andre
hopkins go ahead wax poetically about
yourself oh it's fuller i'm wrong now it
was one of the uh one of the small
opportunities we had throughout the
season where we can uh you know hit one
of the deep shots and you know it gave a
will full of two-way go and uh he hit it
and then this one right here with d-hop
it was just a one-on-one so i just kind
of threw it up and your feet like not
even like this people don't give you
enough credit for how strong your arm is
nah for sure i mean i feel like i could
throw from anywhere on the field so uh
you know it's a confidence day
for me
yeah that was an awesome thought i was
one of the best of the year and then
this is of course a good one too yeah
late season you guys lost i'm sorry but
you only broke 25 tackles here
this is what it was
so i'm trying to make a play and i was
just determined not to go down
you know i kind of peeked up right here
to see where my tight end was and he was
in a spot where we practiced and i kind
of knew where the play was going with
that coverage so he was there so i hit
him i i'm i mean i'm just amazed at you
because you're not like i'm not trying
to be a jerk like you're not the biggest
guy right you're not ben roethlisberger
no not at all but man can you break
tackles and
take hits and that's like the first
thing i want to go like do you worry
about the amount of hits you took this
year uh of course you know the the less
hits i'll take you know sometimes it
kind of you know prolongs your career
but
uh a lot of people don't understand
unless you've been on my team and worked
out with me i'm a lot stronger than i
look yeah and i've always been our way
throughout you know middle school high
school college so uh it's just a
confidence and a mindset that i have all
right all right beat up mike later after
the show in the moment are you thinking
i need to avoid that hit i need to maybe
get out of bounds i need to maybe slide
or you're just focused on doing what you
can to get the ball down the field it
depends on the situation uh sometimes i
kind of just it's my instincts and i try
to you know slide or get out of bounds
but if i need a first down or you know
let's try to get it you know into the
end zone you know i'm gonna try my best
to get into it but also try to protect
myself
you know what i wondered deshawn when
you look at your year this year you were
sacked 62 times
you're not going to be able to live a
long life in the nfl not at all
two times a year and i wonder from 2017
to
2018 how much of an impact was it for
you
coming back from knee surgery did you
feel it at all in 2018
um honestly the the first part where i
felt my knee surgery was at the
beginning because uh you know you can
practice and you can go through training
account but it's really you know
practicing and the game is two different
total tempo so uh you know the first
three games that's where i was kind of
just kind of trying to get the feel of
myself and see if i you know still can
move around but after that from game
four to the rest of the year um i never
had a problem with it yeah desean you
took the nfl by storm as a rookie in
2017. this year patrick mahomes comes
along even though he wasn't a rookie it
was his first year as a starter he takes
the nfl by storm you guys were drafted
two spots apart what kind of
relationship do you guys have and how
much are you looking forward to meeting
him in big games big moments prime time
postseason type atmosphere i mean we've
been we've been boys since coming out of
high school we've trained together all
through college with jordan palmer out
in california um so it's it's you know
things that we talked about for a long
long time and now we have the
opportunity to do it and you know i'm
looking forward to all the big games
that you know of course we're in the afc
so you know hopefully we get that that
peyton and tom brady you know type of
you know match each and every year yeah
when you see him make those crazy throws
does that inspire you to think of hey
what can i do to try to top him uh i
mean not really inspired just because
you know i feel like i can do the same
thing uh my opportunities just haven't
came up yet but uh what about the no
look pass you know look i actually did
one in my rookie year it was one yeah i
was one where i kind of did a play
action and running back instead of flat
and i was looking downfield and i kind
of just threw it sideways
you know and i think it was against
tennessee um early in my my rookie year
but um nah he's doing a heck of a job i
mean that no-look pass is very sweet i
mean i we're talking about it yesterday
after our sunday at the pro bowl when he
tried to hit juju uh how how pretty
sweet it was so it's cool you're you're
aware of like i mean it sounds like
you're aware like the the manning brady
thing like you're saying with my homes
like are you aware like the afc is
setting up with some young qbs right now
right yeah a lot of young a lot of young
quarterbacks that have the potential to
take their teams to you know great
destinations and uh i'm excited for it
yeah
you know another young quarterback who's
coming into the league and we don't know
where he's going to land afc nfc or even
if he's going to play football as kyler
murray right from oklahoma what advice
would you have for him as he's trying to
choose between baseball and football
uh i mean go where your heart is
honestly i mean whatever you feel that
that you feel like you want to be able
to you know have the best career and
that you love the most um you know he
has two great options you know the the
baseball and football and i mean i think
he's choosing football right now and a
lot of people are going to talk bad
about you but don't listen to the
outside noise continue to do what you do
because that's if you do that i mean
you'll be exactly where you want has the
game changed to the point now where you
know you see drew brees you see baker
mayfield you see russell wilson you know
they're all below 6-1 right so now do
you think teams are less scared of a
quarterback who's whatever he is five
nine and a half five ten than they were
a few years ago
uh i think it's 50 50. i guess it
depends on the right system honestly the
system that's going to be able to adapt
to what you can do
um move around in the pocket a little
bit do a lot of play action and kind of
get the defense on their toes but you
know sitting in a pocket you know like a
tom brady and throw it you know 40
sometimes and not moving around it's
gonna be it's pretty tough you know
because it's tough for guys that are six
six and six five to do it you know full
game so um i think you know the right
system would be perfect yeah the the
you've gotten to play the patriots twice
you know here we are in the super bowl
once again and you're they're here again
but what's like jumped out to you when
you've had to face them you know their
defense just what's like the main thesis
about them in your mind i think the
biggest thing is they never do what you
what you saw in the first game right
they always switch it up they always you
know try to find some weakness that you
have in that that that i guess the
previous week and try to exploit that
and uh i feel like they do a good job of
really you know taking advantage of you
know uh you know listening to what you
know bill is doing you know for them on
a defensive side and not you know making
any mistakes what did you think
your your coming out party was the pats
your rookie year where everyone was like
holy crap deshaun watson is so freaking
awesome
but then
but then what about when you played them
to start the season uh 2018. what was
the thing you thought they took away
from you or tried to make life harder on
you with i feel like that they they
disguised a little bit more right and
then also as far as the defensive
lineman they kind of you know pushed the
pocket they didn't let me get outside
the pocket yeah right they kind of had
like a the inside interior guys spying
yeah any time i tried to move they were
just redirecting yeah yeah anything they
kind of did with the patchwork from
homes yes yeah right right yep desean
you've been in the nfl for two years now
whether it's a teammate whether it's an
opponent whether it's somebody you've
never even come across just you've heard
things in the locker room give me one
guy in the nfl that you don't want to
meet in a dark alley in a dark alley
i mean anybody in the dark out
so
you know what i thought you were going
to say jj watt
cool
nah he he's a good guy all right yeah
all right hard hitting questions let's
go enough of this football crap we're
coming on something here did you write
these i can imagine what they are
watch out everybody close your ears at
home
the question is if you can make a phone
call to your younger self
when would when would you call and what
would you say
um deep thoughts it is you definitely
didn't write no i did not um
i'd probably say in high school
um and you know just the younger so i
told the younger self about football
really just the knowledge of the game
you know study defenses um as as much as
you can and be able to you know uh
really just you know to study the game a
little bit more yeah i did before yeah
right because why do you do you think
like when you were young you were so
physically gifted you could just get
away with it away with it right and kind
of use my athletic ability but
now you know looking at it you know as
you get older it gets tough yeah i
thought you'd tell your younger self to
wear old spice
because i mean that's in your future
what are you doing
nah yeah so i'm you know part of old
spice
they have the all-new fresher collection
um and it's the moisturizer with shea
butter and you can get it at walmart so
it's a new collection where you know
women has the more body wash products
but you know they giving man opportunity
to have the same amount of time and
signing the same amount of product
who are you rooting for sunday sunday
so i would just really want a good game
but if i had to pick one
i made it be cool to see the rams yeah
we've seen the patriots enough yeah
right it'd be cool to see rams and jerry
golf and i'm
great friends with uh todd gurley so
it'd be cool to see him get one yeah the
rest of america loves you now
yeah it'd be cool to see the texas well
there's a sixth state region that
doesn't love that right yeah
but you know we've seen you here the
last three years you were coming in as a
rookie a couple of years ago last year
we had you here maybe next year we won't
see you because you'll be in one of the
hotels in miami getting ready for super
bowl 15. let's go man get it done got it
got it done all right quick break more
pfc live thanks to sean great talking to
you as always we'll be back more pft
live right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports